- Hi
(audience applauding)
- I like that.
This is so fun.
- I'm gonna tell my stylist
to get me that.
That's really cute.
How have you been?
- I'm great. I'm great.
- Yeah?
- By the way,
congratulations on the show-
- Thank you-
- And all your success.
- It's so random.
And it was funny cause you were coming
and I was like, how full
circle moment is this?
'Cause like, right after I won "Idol,"
they rushed us to New York,
and y'all, you were one of
my first interviews ever.
- That's right.
- So I feel intimidated,
but I'm gonna be fine.
- No, don't be intimidated.
It was so funny because I remember,
you were super hoarse,
you were on this whirlwind
24 hour press thing,
'cause you had just won.
It was so exciting.
And I remember saying,
"I can't wait to see what
happens to you in the future."
- Boy, me neither.
- Look at her.
- No. Yeah.
(audience cheering)
Nobody knew, including me.
- Who knew?
- Yeah, no, definitely not me.
I was like "Well I should
be able to pay my bills
for a minute.
(Katie laughing)
- So, what was your most,
'cause this is the thing.
This show isn't live.
That's a whole different situation
when you're doing live stuff.
Like when I host award shows,
it's a different animal.
So out of the "Today
Show" all those years,
like what was your most
favorite like unplanned moment?
- Well, I have a lot of them,
you know.
- Okay.
- But I did the show for 15 years.
I think, well, one time
a woman exposed herself
when she was out on the Plaza
and the rest of the anchors-
- Did you throw her beads?
- No, but I was,
(audience laughing)
I was on a remote location
and the rest of the anchors,
she was behind them.
So they didn't see anything.
So basically you see
saw me in the box going.
(Kelly laughing)
And so that was great. I
mean, there's been a lot.
And then I was interviewing Barbara Bush
at the White House for the
anniversary of the White House
and we were getting a whole tour
and suddenly her husband,
President George Herbert Walker Bush,
walked in with their dog
and I had to do an impromptu
19 minute interview
that I hadn't prepared for-
- I bet those 19 minutes
- Which was really-
- Lasted forever.
- Oh my God.
(everyone laughing)
I was so pitted out
and it was so stressful
and I kept thinking, I'm
gonna run outta questions.
I'm gonna start asking him,
"What's your favorite food
here at the White House?"
- Oh my gosh.
- Or, you know,
but it all worked out.
- Oh, that's so cool though.
That's a really cool
impromptu kind of interview.
- Yeah,
- Nobody gets
that chance often.
- I know
- It's cool.
- It was funny.
I can't believe that he decided to walk in
in the middle of our
interview, but he did,
and it was great and-
- I love that.
- That was when I had first
started on the "Today Show"
so-
- Oh my God.
- It was a big moment for me.
- It's like, welcome.
- Definitely.
- Wait, I wanna talk about this too
because you just turned 65, right?
Did I hear right that you're 65
and you're doing 65 acts of kindness.
- I am.
- I love that.
- You know, I don't need
a darn thing, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah, no, I get it
- I've been so blessed.
And I thought, what can I do
that maybe will spread joy
and maybe encourage other
people to follow suit.
So I said, I'm 65.
I'm gonna do, in addition
to signing up for Medicare,
I'm gonna get 60,
I'm gonna do 60-
(everyone laughing)
It's really depressing
when you get those notifications.
I mean, getting like my
ARP card was bad enough.
- Whatever! It's a discount people!
(Katie laughing)
- Oh, I know!
- A discount is always awesome.
- I guess I'm eligible
for the senior discount.
- I'm just saying.
I told my mom, my mom got so mad.
I called her, I don't
know what age it was,
but it was like, she turned
a certain age, I was like,
"Girl you can get me some
free food at Denny's."
I was like, "You can give me like half off
and like, I'm like, I'm
taking you everywhere."
I was like, she didn't think it was funny.
- She didn't? I think it's funny.
- I think she thinks of
age differently than me.
(both laughing)
- But I'm doing,
you know, I'm trying to
just do things every day
that are acts of kindness, you know?
For someone.
- I think it's a good thing,
though, to put in your brain, though,
'cause it makes you start,
like, I know you're doing 65
but it'll probably get you in the habit
of everyday kind of thinking like that,
which is what we all should do.
- Definitely.
And I want everyone to
kind of follow suit, so.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you can do your age.
- The world needs it.
- Or you can do more than your age, right?
- I'm gonna be 40 this year. I'll do it.
I'll do it just for today.
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
- That would be fun.
- I know.
- You should do it
on the show.
- I will do it on the,
she has just made it so.
(audience applauding)
She has just made it so.
We will do something
with the show.
- I'm now producing
"The Kelly Clarkson Show."
- It's a good idea though.
We love giving people stuff here.
But also, wait, speaking of that.
So March is, I wanna say this
right, colorectal, right?
- Yes, colorectal.
- I always feel like
I'm saying it wrong.
Okay.
- Yeah, I know.
- I know, everybody says it differently.
Okay, so March is Colorectal
Cancer Awareness Month
and I know that you're a big advocate
of people getting screened, right?
- Yes.
- I've actually, polyps run in our family,
so I've already done it
and I'm only 39, but like-
- Well I'm glad 'cause-
- People should get checked out.
- Yeah, definitely.
This is so important.
Let me use this as a sounding board
because, you know, it's so
many people don't get screened
and the American Cancer Society
lowered the screening age
to 45.
- Yeah.
- Because we're seeing many more cases
of colorectal cancer and
people under the age of 50.
- So I've teamed up with Exact Sciences.
They're the maker of Cologuard
because while I got a
colonoscopy on the "Today Show"
to spread awareness after Jay died,
there a lot of different screening options
that are available.
- Yeah.
- And so I just want people to know
that it's highly preventable,
but the least prevented cancer.
There are more than 40 million
people at average risk.
Not like you who have polyps
or somebody who has a family history.
- Yeah.
- Who aren't getting screened
and it can be really
stopped in it's tracks
if you detect it or early.
- Yeah.
- When it's most treatable
or, you know, it's just, you
can breathe a sigh of relief.
So I really want everyone-
- And why not just try?
- If they they're 45 or if
they know someone who's 45
and they haven't been screened
to talk to their doctor about
different screening options,
including ones that don't require prep
and don't make you miss a day
of work.
- Yeah.
- But it's super, super important.
'Cause I don't want-
- And it's worth it.
- People to be saying, "If only."
- Exactly, if I would've
caught it, that's my thing.
And that's, with me, I had
no issues, no complications
but my family, I knew
had polyps in the past
like a lot of people-
- You're lucky.
- So that's why I did it.
I was like, and then I was fine
but isn't that worth it?
Like knowing that you're fine.
- Yes!
- Like, you know what I'm saying?
- Or if you're not fine-
- That's even better.
- The earlier you detect it-
- The better chance.
- Through screening, the better chance
that you'll continue to be fine.
- Yeah.
- Just get screened, everybody, please.
(audience applauding)
- And it's not a big deal.
I think everybody made it a big deal.
I was freaked out going in
'cause I was like, "Wait,
what are they gonna do?"
And then it's like not a big deal.
- Yeah.
- Anyway.
- It's really, really important
and I'm happy
because I have such a personal
connection to the disease.
I know what it can do to someone.
And that's why I've become-
- And to the family.
It's hard to watch, yeah.
- Oh, yeah, of course.
I mean, Ellie and Carrie grew up
without their wonderful father
and without my incredible husband. And so-
- I love that you talk about
that though, in your book.
Being single, you know,
and crushing it still.
'Cause I think it's a
hard thing, women always,
and I felt this,
like maybe a few years ago.
I was like, "Ooh, how do you balance?"
I really love my job.
I love what I do.
I love that I get to help people.
But you know, I'm a single mom now
and it's hard to find that balance
and you wanna be there for everything.
But-
- I think the time you're with them,
you have to really be focused
and make sure it's quality time.
Like don't be on your phone,
really be focused on them.
And I think for them to see
you going out in the world,
doing great things,
bringing people happiness.
- Yeah.
- You know, putting great
things into the world.
I remember when Ellie was nine,
she looked at me in the kitchen,
We were like setting the table,
and she said,
"Mom, I'm so proud of
the work you're doing
with colon cancer."
- Oh wow.
- So they watch you and I
think they learn from you.
And I think they appreciate things
that you're doing outside the home too.
So don't feel guilty
- In honor of Colorectal Cancer Month,
and your 65 acts of kindness this year,
our show is gonna donate
$5,000 to Stand Up To Cancer.
- Oh!
(audience cheering)
And hopefully everybody out there,
y'all can pitch in as well.
Her new book is called "Going There."
In the book, you talk about
many people from your past.
Did it feel good to get things out there?
I feel terrified to do
something like this.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Well, you know,
as my husband, John said,
"If you're gonna write a
book, you have to be honest."
- Exactly.
- And I sort of thought,
what is the point of, kind,
of sugar coating everything?
So I'm very honest about,
and introspective about
mistakes I've made,
shortcomings, failures,
triumphs, tragedies.
Sort of, the whole gamut of
what makes up a full life.
And so, you know, I think
when you're a public figure,
I'm sure you could relate to this, Kelly,
what happens is everyone writes about you
but you never really
get to tell your story.
And people who write about
you often have an agenda,
or they're doing it for
clicks, or whatever reason.
So I was able to really do, you know,
talk about what it felt like
from this vantage point.
- Yeah.
- And plus, I love to write.
It's sort of funny.
The book is.
There are places where it's
really heartbreaking and sad,
but I did it for my daughters
because I feel like we all
have these stories to tell,
and these circumstances that shaped us.
And we used to kind of,
I have so many letters
from my great grandmother,
and my mom saved everything,
my dad was a saver too.
But because we don't
write letters anymore,
some of our history is evaporating.
So I urge everybody to write things down,
even if, you know, even if
they don't get it published
because people want to
have their family history.
And if your kids aren't interested now,
they will one day really
wanna know about my mother
and my father and my grandparents.
And after all this, you
know, I love my book.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's my favorite book.
- I love it!
(audience applauding)
That's amazing!
My book is my favorite book.
You also talk about your current marriage.
So what was dating like, I
don't know, in your 50's?
That's a different age
for some people.
- Yeah.
So I was 41 when Jay died.
And so, you know, after a couple years,
I realized I needed to dip my
toe back into the dating pool
'cause I'm also a real partner person.
- Yeah.
- I'm not good alone.
And I like to have companionship.
- Yeah.
- So I started dating.
I had some, you know,
relationships that didn't
necessarily pan out
which you can read about in my book.
(everyone laughing)
Including with a guy 17
years younger than I was.
- Oh really?
I have a girlfriend like you.
See-
- Now what do you mean,
you have a girlfriend like me?
This was one time.
- I'm just saying, I have
a girlfriend like you.
She's attracted to younger guys.
I'm like, I don't wanna be a teacher.
Like I'm not here to be a teacher.
- Oh, what did they say?
I'd rather be a nurse.
Wait, what do they say?
I'd rather be a babysitter than a nurse.
- No, no, no.
(Katie laughing)
I don't wanna be either one.
(both laughing)
- But anyway, so, but I did,
I've been married for seven years now.
I met an incredible person.
- That's so cool.
- I could not be happier and-
(audience sighing)
There he is!
- So great.
- He's so great
and he puts up with me.
I'm a total mess.
He's super neat.
And he calls me tornado and-
- Oh, you're actually messy like-
- I'm messy. I'm messy.
- Oh my gosh. I'm opposite.
- In fact, I think he posted on Instagram,
a shot of my toothpaste tubes
that was squeezed in the middle.
Oh.
And then he said, why does
she have seven toothbrushes?
(audience laughing)
And that's an excellent question-
- Why do you have?
And you might be asking the same question.
It's 'cause I travel
and I always forget it.
- Oh, the hotel?
- Then I get one from the hotel
or I go to a local drug store
and then I have a
perfectly good toothbrush-
- And you feel wasteful.
- I don't wanna throw it away.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I just add it to my collection.
- Yeah. Some people
call that hoarder, but-
(everyone laughing)
- I do have sort of
hoarder tendencies, Kelly.
(both laughing)
- Okay. So wait, I wanna talk about this
'cause you started your
own media company and-
- Yes.
- Was the reason behind it
'cause you wanted,
I know a lot of people,
it's confusing right now.
Like people don't know
who to trust or whatever.
Is this kind of the
backbone of why you did it?
- Well, I had worked at
so many different networks
and in so many different jobs
and I think in this day and age,
there's so much content out there,
so much information, 24/7,
it's kind of inundated.
You're inundated with that.
- And people just lie.
- Yeah. Right.
- So that's hard.
- And there's a lot of
misinformation out there.
So I thought, you know, I've
been doing this a long time.
A lot of people know me and trust me.
And so I said, "I wanna
create a media company"
and I did it.
I'm doing it with my husband, John.
He's the CEO,
'cause I'm sort of more
the creative person.
He's a very strong, smart-
- Business minded, yeah.
- Businessman.
And so we have a
newsletter, "Wake Up Call,"
which, you know,
basically gives all the
news you need to know
and helps,
we have medical information,
health and wellness,
lifestyle, fashion, all
sorts of different things
in just one digestible
email every morning,
called "Wake Up Call."
Then I have a podcast that I've
been doing for a few years.
I'm developing some documentaries
and scripted projects.
So basically-
- Wow.
- We're doing so many
things at the company,
it's just really exciting.
- It's fun you get
to do with him too, yeah.
- It's great to be the boss
of you, isn't it?
♪ Amen ♪
- Yes!
(audience applauding)
- Right?
- Yes.
It is.
It's cool that you get to
work with your husband too
while doing it.
- Yeah.
- That's really cool.
That y'all get to do something
so beautiful together.
- Yeah. We haven't killed each other yet.
So that's positive.
(Kelly laughing)
We have a lot of, you know, young people
and young women who I wanna kind of,
share my knowledge of the industry,
help them learn to do-
- Yeah. Mentorship.
- What they really wanna do.
And it's exciting to
be able to mentor them.
- That's really cool.
- Yeah.
- Helping them get
where you were.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's
awesome. That's awesome.
Everybody, Katie's book
is called "Going There."
You should check it out
'cause it's awesome.
As well as her "Wake Up Call" newsletter
and her podcast which is called,
"Next Question With Katie Couric."
She's got all the things going on, y'all.
You got to check it out.